foreign
sex addiction therapist he cheated on my
mom with one of his clients at the time
he was 63 years old she was 29.
I haven't spoken to him in about five
months and I'm just wondering where do I
go from here
[Music]
what's up this is John with the Dr John
deloney show
the greatest mental health and podcasts
parenting and everything else podcast
ever
so glad that you're with us
talking about whatever's going on in
your life the good stuff the hard stuff
the messy stuff if you want to be on the
show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-329-1 it's 1-844-693-329
one love to chat with you we could hang
out for a while and figure out
whatever's going on all right let's go
to Daniel in Lexington Kentucky what's
up Daniel how we doing
pretty good how you doing Dr deloney
good man good good good good so what's
up
my main question I have for you is how
do I go with the disgust I have toward
my dad
oh man right when you said how do I I
started to sing that song but this is
actually a serious question man how do
we leave so um like uh
why are you disgusted with your dad
well
first of all I gotta say the story is
like an onion there is just layer upon
layer upon layer so I'll I'll try to
tell pretty much everything in under a
couple minutes or so cool
um so I'm 29 I'm a husband father of
three my dad is a sex addiction
therapist uh two years ago he cheated on
my mom with one of his clients in his
office
at the time he was 63 years old she was
29.
so
as a result my mom divorced my dad they
were married for 43 years
uh and there's some important details
about his mistress so after this all
happened
I learned that she served an eight-year
prison sentence for sexual enticement of
a minor and after her she served her
prison time she was ordered by a judge
to receive Psychotherapy which is why
she was seeing my dad so the story
behind why she went to prison in the
first place is that at one point she was
working as a prostitute and exposed
herself to two 12 year old boys
so it gets worse
so uh when she was young she was in a
car accident and it left her with some
residual brain damage so I met her in
person and she still struggles with some
executive brain function I'm not a
psychologist but
um I would say she has the cognitive
function of a 13 year old person
probably which just adds to how you know
unethical this was okay
so shockingly my dad uh decided to marry
this woman
um and even to this day he doesn't
really believe that he's done anything
unethical he justifies it by saying that
it was consensual
so
um I will say that there he's been
reported to the Licensing Division and
um there's an investigation going on
right now so here's what I really need
help with
um so I obviously I feel a lot of
disgust towards my dad and really the
entire situation I feel a lot of
resentment and I feel abandoned and
betrayed but if I'm really honest with
myself I also miss him deeply from my
life and my kids lives as well so I
haven't spoken to him in about five
months and I'm just wondering where do I
go from here
huh
I'm sorry man
on 50 different counts I'm sorry
um
this this is a messy situation that is
much simpler than it feels and much
um heavier than you probably think it's
going to be over the long term okay
um the chance that this was the first
time this happened is virtually zero
oh I I know it's not the first time it's
happened okay all right so
um it's very rare that a somebody who
deals in the intimacy of other people's
lives who is a person of this kind of
character wouldn't have done this
multiple times and
that you will you you get four or five
drinks and your mom she might tell you
all about some stories that have
happened along the years right
um yeah here's the deal that's not gonna
change where you find yourself you find
yourself disgusted with a guy let me
tell you where a lot of us don't realize
how deep this disgust goes
because as much as we don't want to
think about it or believe it or we don't
even consider it
we all know deep down that half of us as
Mom and half of us as Dad
and if he is capable of this what am I
capable of because I'm part of him and
he's part of me
right yeah it's unnerving it makes it
particularly close and then you throw it
on top the confusion of I actually like
the guy and I miss him being around but
he's also disgusting like and then you
just find yourself in this Vortex right
yeah so here's the heartbreaking thing
he has opted out of your life not the
other way around
yeah I think that's true he opted out of
your mom's life he opted out of your
life
um and he's thrown away his entire
career he's going to be found guilty all
right we know that uh he'll be found
guilty because they're going to take his
text messages they're going to take his
uh emails they're going to take all of
his clinical records and probably dig up
the times this has happened in the past
so it's the the it will be a hurricane
Cha-Cha storm diarrhea storm coming down
the road
um and he
walked into it all right
and I I have a very little sympathy for
somebody in his case because people come
to him and they're most vulnerable and
they come to him with a particularly
vulnerable thing which is I'm addicted
to relationship right and he abused that
and so I I don't got a lot I'm disgusted
by him too let me say that
um yeah and I mean that's that's why I
view her as a victim really in this
situation I mean I feel absolutely on
some level absolutely absolutely yeah
she went to a professional for help and
took advantage of that help so
the the thing you can do is walk away
and after you walk away
um
any choice you make to go back and be
redisgusted and rediscussed it as a
choice you're making to be more
miserable in the present I wouldn't do
that
yeah you know what I mean there's no
sense in poisoning yourself
you do have to reckon with
um
that guy's part of me and what am I
doing in my life that could ever even
have a a the faintest trail into the
woods that would lead me down a path
like this
right is there anything in yourself that
makes you uncomfortable or is this just
your dad off the rails
um
sad you know okay
um it I it often when our parents do
things there's Echoes inside of us
yeah I think the I think the the what
makes it particularly difficult is
growing up I I I always thought of him
as for the most part a really good while
they're teaching you know good values
and so after this has happened it's sort
of it's sort of like well was all that
fake was all that an act you know like
that's that those are the thoughts that
are going through my mind like were
those things that I was even taught was
it even real because the person who
taught it to me
just totally went the opposite direction
you know and you're 29 right now
yeah that's right you'd be having these
thoughts anyway
like 20 27 28 to 33 35 that's when you
start pulling the thread on is this real
and you because you start moving up the
professional ladder and you look behind
the curtain and you realize oh my boss
doesn't know what he's doing at all and
you your doctor has a different
conversation they're like I don't know
man I gotta go check with a colleague
and you think I thought y'all know
everything right so this is the season
when everything like your friend gets
fired or your wife gets fired or
something like that so this is the
season when everything starts unwinding
a little bit and then the the thing you
were anchored into the man that you
anchored into
turns out he wasn't concrete he's just a
Mist right and the Temptation is to
throw everything out
don't do that if he gave you good wisdom
and good values even though he wasn't
using them
um
honor those things right
yeah but yeah you're married
yeah okay you ever cheat on your spot on
your on your wife
no uh
don't okay
okay yeah I won't I know but don't
yeah we learn our behaviors right
right and cheating starts with Cuban
secrets
and cheating starts with flirting here
in the office and cheating starts right
see what I'm saying so I want you to
Sure hold the thread on those you're
you're you're suddenly going uh uh
these are when our parents screw up it
echoes through us okay
not to say that you're some a sex
criminal which is what I think your dad
is but uh you do
um
you do have these Echoes In your own
soul okay
and man you got to walk away he left you
and now you're just standing there you
got to go be about your life and I know
that's so hard man here's the way like
tactically here's how we do this number
one you're gonna write him a letter
okay and I it might be one that you
consider mailing to him
okay normally we write these letters and
it's not one of rage and anger and uh
like some out of some some superiority
it's out but feel free to let him know
like you broke my heart man
because you didn't tell the truth and
you've been cheating on mom for years
and you left Mom for somebody who's
um psychologically not well it's
cognitive deficiencies and he chose to
walk away from my family and let him
know I mean put it in writing until you
make different choices and here's what
those are gonna be
um you've opted out of being around my
family and your grandkids and fill in
the blank and I'm gonna miss you
terribly and I hate that you made these
choices and um
let him know
but my thought is if you sat down and
had a conversation with him he's
probably good enough on his feet and you
would leave that
pretty confused is that right
yeah we've had those conversations
before and I it just feels as if nothing
really sticks yeah he's probably a good
talker yeah he can Loop you up in spin
in circles right yeah that's what he
does yeah yeah that's his career that's
his craft that's who he is right
um yeah write it down man and then at
some point you're gonna have to write
yourself a letter
mm-hmm you to you and be really upset be
really honest about the good stuff he
gave you and then be really clear about
what you're going to do next
yeah okay is that fair
yeah and then some days You're Gonna
wake up and just miss him like crazy and
that's what your boundaries are for
you're not going to reach out you're not
going to text him you're gonna have
somebody else to call you're gonna call
your wife you're gonna have already
thought that through and some days
You're Gonna wake up and be so enraged
and pissed off or some days You're Gonna
wake up and your mom's gonna have texted
you and just like with a long text or a
short text and it's going to break your
heart and you're going to get so pissed
and all those feelings are okay the real
question is what are you gonna do after
that
right right yeah and when those feelings
pop into your head and you have those
moments more than five seconds on them
is a choice I'm gonna just choose to I'm
gonna make cereal and I'm just gonna pee
in it just cause I'm just gonna eat that
for breakfast I think it's just a choice
it's just a strange bizarre choice
or when those lightning bolts pop into
our head we can go oh my gosh that guy's
the worst
my wife is incredible I'm so grateful
for this home that I live I'm so
grateful I'm sitting in an office right
now I'm a fortunate guy and then we're
gonna go about our day that way and
that's something you're going to
practice over time it's going to be hard
sorry this happened to you man
um
can't imagine finding this out about my
father
I can't because I'm anchored into them
I'm anchored into them I can't imagine
finding this out I'm sorry this happened
um it's very simple you gotta have the
boundaries and it's gonna be very very
hard over a long period of time
holler at me as you go man I'm here to
walk with you we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com
deloni and get the home buyer Edge today
this is a paid advertisement and MLS ID
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org Equal
Housing lender 1749 Mallory Lane Suite
100 Brentwood Tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and not
available in all states or locations
all right we're back let's go to Lola in
canoxville in Knoxville Tennessee what's
up Lola
excited when you all selected me because
I'm in such a pickle and you're so smart
so thanks for taking my calls I like
pickles and I'm not that smart so one
out of two ain't so bad so what's up
okay so I'm in a pickle what have you
done what have you done Lola oh
did you really do something this is so
great oh I can't wait okay what is it
okay so my husband and I have the
door and my mother-in-law and
father-in-law live six houses down from
us
and when I was pregnant my mother-in-law
hated her job and we needed child care
so we begged her to retire and watch
you know I already know you're the worst
Lola the worst
I mean I was like oh this is perfect and
I work from home and so it was gonna be
this just this great setup
um
so she agreed
um but she said I'm taking an 1800 a
month hit by retiring early at 62
instead of 67 and she said unfortunately
I'm just gonna need some money to to um
to live and so we agreed and like
happily I agreed and we pay her 600 a
month and she relies on that income
um and so it was just like it it was
just the Stars aligned and so yeah
forward the worst Lola this is like a
slow-moving train wreck yeah we all know
how this part of the movie ends so good
no I know well I know okay so keep going
you're not the worst by the way um okay
keep going
forward
um yeah I've been back at work for a
year
and
um I see I guess the part that I didn't
incorporate in my equation was
um I'm not it's like I need knew I would
need child care but I didn't think about
how I would actually want to spend time
with my son
um that like that just wasn't even like
a thought and so
um now I am
um going like every break that I get I
start as late as I can I finish as early
as I can his bedtime is 8 30 and he naps
for three to three and a half hours in
the middle of the day so that I can have
more wake time with him at night like
I'm always clawing at time with him
um and I am and I'm working full-time
now I work from home and my job I love
my job I've been here for seven and a
half years and I like I I love
everything about it it gives me so much
purpose and I make I mean I make good
money too and so
um but I'm just so tired and
um and and my husband and I you know we
really want to move out to The Burbs and
have like you know like a pool and
walking trails we can't do that because
I mean I'm not gonna drive to and from
the suburbs every day and drop him off
um that's that's going to be like a
two-hour commute I'm not doing that Lola
this has nothing to do with your
mother-in-law
but you just have to do it you
well I mean do you think that I'm just
being
um I think you have I think you are a
mother of a 15 year old son and you love
him very much and you had a very clear
plan of what was going to happen next
and that plan is an ash because you
looked at those two little those two
little eyes of that sweet little boy
and everything blew up
I'm missing three hours awake time a day
with him
partially or all of your salary and then
like what do we do with my mother-in-law
I mean she needs much she needs our
income that's your husband men tend to
solve problems with spreadsheets okay
right and especially your husband and
your mother-in-law yeah she's in a mess
like she's kind of getting hosed here
there's no there's no getting around
that
you are you are you are experiencing in
real time
the hell that is modern American
motherhood
which is you cannot win
it is a guilt Factory if you go to work
full time and make five hundred thousand
dollars
someone's ER not someone you you're
gonna look in the mirror and go what
kind of mother are you
and then you say you're right I'm
sacrificing all this for my kid you're
gonna quit and then you're gonna stare
at that little lump and go what have I
done who am I I'm not even contributing
I'm such a loser and there's and then
you're gonna go to Facebook or Instagram
or Pinterest to make yourself feel
better and then you're just going to
want to set yourself on fire to see if
your makeup is flammable right there's
no way out you're just in it this is so
accurate like yes and so it says your
mother-in-law yes she's going to be a
casualty of whatever happens here but
she's not the problem
the problem is you want it all and you
want it all right now and gosh freaking
you had it on a plan it was on my
manifest board and it's what it's going
to look like and it's not gonna happen
that way
would I be putting I'm worried about
putting
yes
do you know our question's gonna be I
don't even I don't care what the
question could be I know what the answer
is going to be what's your question
I worry in this economy on putting like
all of the financial responsibility on
my husband and then now he's gonna have
to worry about his I mean what do I do
uh so I think you do it in a particular
order okay are you gonna quit my job
like you're telling me no no
I'm about to ask you are you gonna quit
your job
take all of the pools take all of the I
shoulds and shouldn't take all that junk
all that crap off the table
take all of the mother-in-law and is my
husband gonna have to actually take all
that off
are you gonna quit your job
well I mean like that's dependent on the
answer to those
it's not those questions are dependent
on that answer
and here's the thing there's not a right
or wrong to it
there's a seasonal response
and you my good friend are so good at
clouding up simple decision simple
questions with noise because that's how
you get through all hard things
so you're so good at it
like I need to have a hard conversation
with my husband but I can make a good
dinner and we can go do this and it'll
be fun we'll go to the show and then it
will just go away it doesn't ever go
away
I mean I just
um I just like I feel like I can't win
you can't you can't that's why you just
got to go forward
you got to do the best thing right now
and that thing by the way will change
and it might mean what do we do with my
mother-in-law though do we like I mean I
think I think the ethical fair thing is
to give her a pretty long Runway
yeah if anybody in the world would
understand I'm a mom
and I feel like I'm watching my son's
life slip through my fingers while I'm
here typing away on design spreadsheets
or something I don't know what you do
for a living but like I I feel like I'm
missing it
um whatever it is right and by the way
it
is insanely boring
maddeningly boring
well like being a mom being a
stay-at-home mom oh my gosh I mean
unfathomably boring
and it's right
do you think I'm Trading
did come back to work and the reason
they did was because we all have similar
situations where it's just like
it's not like we have to sit in traffic
for two hours a day and we don't like
it's not like we're only seeing two
hours a day with them like I see a lot
of him I just I don't see huh what are
you missing
I'm missing three to four hours a day of
wake time okay
and and because I have to put him down
so late to get that wake time I feel
like I mean I'm just so tired because I
feel like I'm doing
two full-time jobs like I see six to
seven hours a day of him awake he's only
awake for like
whatever
nine I mean but some of this is very
very seasonal you're talking like six
more months
what do you mean like in just a few more
months he's gonna start napping way way
less and be way more all over the place
and then in a year and a half he's going
to be in a Tuesday Thursday school and
then in two more years or three more
years he's going to be in kindergarten
it goes so fast
and so
I like right now you are making a very
static long-term decision on a very
fluid situation
so I'm wondering if I could just add
what if I drop down to part-time then
you I'm not you you have spit your
entire how many people did you ask if
your husband was the right guy to marry
probably a thousand
um well yeah the first two years when we
were dating yes like every single thing
that came up I had advice from my
girlfriend yes we need to get a copy we
gotta talk let's go talk let's go get
drink I gotta talk yes you Lola I'm not
taking this from you you're gonna have
to be all grown up
oh but you're John deloney exactly I'm
not gonna take your decision because
here's why you also blame everybody when
you do take their advice and you gotta
own this one
right you know what whenever I was on
maternity leave I told my husband I said
I cannot imagine
like I love my job but like what I'm not
gonna have 24 hours a day with him like
what am I going to be doing during this
time and so I said can I just take like
18 months off until he becomes a toddler
because when he's a toddler it's like
more work and whatever and he like
mansplained me out of it but my
mother-in-law heard that I was
considering it and so she texted him and
said hey is Lola gonna gonna take some
time off because if so I'm just gonna
push my I'm going to push my retirement
back I can't afford to retire without
this and so then he like mansplained me
out of it he was like but this and this
and this and this and you can see him
during your breaks and you know look at
all of this future that you can provide
and whatever and so I like when I I
didn't and also like all the
consequences of I'm in a senior level
position at work and it's like I haven't
made and all of this stuff and so I knew
about it and so when you say blaming
others I mean I did tell him before she
was actually retired like hey like I
don't know if I I don't know if I'm able
to get my baby up and you know he talks
me out of it and I'm like still feeling
the same thing I was feeling a year ago
and you're right like I just feel
kind a little bit of his time flipping
through but then also like I see so much
little like I see
um like my entire life revolved around
him because you're a working mom like I
don't get my nails done anymore I know I
know but listen listen this this is this
is it
here's what you haven't done yet
um you've probably heard me say this in
the show before and I'll say it again
when when my wife got pregnant with Hank
my my 12 year old
I literally started a clock
like okay nine to ten months and I'll
get my wife back
and what that meant was not she didn't
go anywhere and she was still awesome
we're still having fun but like in nine
or ten months like like the Disco lights
come back on we can just make out in the
middle of the night if we want to we
just go like hey let's just go to
Denny's it's 2 A.M I know let's just do
it like like we had this life let's just
drive to Dallas and go to a concert
let's do it like we had this life and I
kept waiting until that life could would
come back
and it wasn't until my son because I'm
in hard-headed [ __ ] it wasn't until I
was he was eight or nine or ten and I'd
almost blown up everything
that I realized oh that life is over
it doesn't exist anymore and you haven't
done that yet so I'm just gonna be
perpetually exhausted for the next 18
years whether I'm working
congratulations welcome to Parenthood
myself listen when I told my Dad hey Dad
we're having a I'm having a baby
he said well
you're never going to sleep again that
was the first thing he said
because he's a he's a brilliant
pragmatist so yes you're going to be
tired for the rest of days
yes you know why even if I quit my job
and I don't have to work and I just have
to hold him I'll still be tired and I
just have him all still be tired you are
smarter than the answer is yes yes and
the booth all the parents back here are
dying laughing they're all laughing yes
yes I just watch a TV
nope
in 2048 you can watch whatever show you
wanted
whatever show you want to
and here's what's so hey can I tell you
what's so great about this you're about
three months away from one either you or
your husband being like you wanna have
another one and be like yep
I'm just refusing to have another he
said he's totally done he said under no
circumstances we're totally done okay
can I be super like I've been laughing
with you because I know this is
miserable and I also know like like
here's me being very serious
um
you and your husband are not on the same
page and this is a recipe for a mess
down the road
and you are super fun and you'd be
really fun to like get beers with it
hang out I can already I can tell you
you're fun but you avoid hard
conversations with him and you cave
and there's gonna come a point when that
caving is gonna turn into a nightmare
Bernie like he is so good at making his
point and it makes so much sense
um and so yeah but but you're not you
and your son's relationship is not a
spreadsheet
it's not a problem to solve
your financial situation if you quit an
incredible job might be a financial
problem to solve but that comes on the
back end of what's right right now
and you keeping your job and finding
ways I guarantee it I guarantee it
there are ways for you to rest in this
season
it's going to take a you're gonna have
to back out and say what has to go
um I'm trying to figure out what that is
I know and there's you want to do
everything all at the same time you just
can't
and so I it sounds to me like you have
the greatest possible situation
which is I've got somebody that I trust
who I actually love who's not a maniac
taking care of my kid inside my house
that I can see him all the time and I'm
making a killer salary
and that's when you and your husband
need to go out and stop doing a hey
here's a feeling I have here's a concern
I have boom here's a spreadsheet answer
like you can't live like that
we do I know but here's what's gonna
happen you're gonna go on a business
conference and someone's gonna listen to
you for the first time
and nothing's gonna happen and you're
going to text or you're gonna get their
email address and say hey it was great
to talk to you and now you're off
somewhere else
that's how that happens
or your husband's gonna get not like the
person he becomes because he's trying to
make love to a spreadsheet and he's
going to begin to want to become a
different person
this is how this happens okay
ah
and you 100 know I'm right
okay one more okay serious question one
more my dad died of a heart attack
because he was working so much because
my my stepmom milked him for every penny
that that he had and then my husband's
dad died like very similarly like
ex-wife baby mama drama child support
all of that and so like I mean would I
be putting his health at risk or like
you know like by to eliminate I mean we
could we would be fine with if I quit or
drop down to part-time but like I just
feel guilty like especially in Peak
inflation and all that I mean
what do you think about the added
pressure on a man to like the like have
to support a family I would say that my
wife made an incredible income when she
was a fancy research professor
and then when I wasn't well and we took
a 70 000 house dollar household income
pay cut 70 grand and we moved to a new
town so I could work with a smaller
group of students and get my head
screwed back on
and she worked part-time there and she
worked part-time and volunteered and was
a writer and whatever else she did
and I struggled a just because of the
math because I wanted to look at the
spreadsheet and had some financial goals
and I got tired of driving her old
Corolla around right and I was making a
great salary as the dean of students at
a law school is making a great salary as
the chief student affairs officer at
College X and Y like but it wasn't
manifesting it wasn't playing out my
life because I was the only guy right
yeah and then here's what happened I got
my wife back
I got my life back I got my kids back
and there is no dollar amount for that
I'll drive a Corolla till the end of
time
yeah
see what I'm saying but yeah it also
took us going to counseling and learning
how to have a new kind of relationship
it also took um several years of us in
several near misses to recalibrate our
marriage because it was just super
different it was a different marriage
than the one that we had when we first
got married it was just a totally
different one
yeah
and so
that's the work ahead of you it's in in
here's the thing you're gonna quit your
job and you're going to be so frustrated
that you're broke or that you have to
drive old cars or that you can't move or
you might have to move you might have to
downsize well he would just need to stop
playing golf like as much as he normally
does that's really like like it's fine
it's just he is
this is 100 percent
this is you caught in the system that's
that's the air right there's no getting
around that
you all need to go talk to somebody
I'm just telling you and he's gonna say
why what oh you only play golf fine I'll
quit playing that's not it that's not it
it's not it
it's beneath that it's that you have a
picture of what this whole thing's
supposed to look like and it's not gonna
happen
and he has a picture of what it's going
to look like and it's not gonna happen
it's not and that is the beauty
of being married and that's the beauty
of it all like of playing forward is you
don't know how it's going to wrap up but
it's not going to be this and so you can
do one of two things you can just keep
trying to make this thing happen until
you crash this sucker into the ditch
or you can say all right that picture's
over that was a blast now we got to do
something new and in this new picture
you're gonna play less Golf and be
around more
in this new picture we're going to cut
our expenses by 25 I'm going to sell the
new car and I'm gonna buy an old car
that can get me to and from and
um
by the way you can put two or three car
seats in a Corolla nobody's gonna die
right you're gonna look ridiculous and
you're going to be like have to squish
and squeeze and lean overnight it's
frustrating but you can be just fine
okay
so why am I saying that you can cut
expenses Lola it's deciding we want this
over this
and this over this is an admission that
we can't have everything all the time
right now
just is it just is
I don't think you should quit your job
if I'm being I'm just Insurgent I don't
think you should quit your job because I
think you love your job
I think your marriage is a mess
I think your marriage is messier than
you want to admit it and I think that is
making the ground you walk on very
unstable
because you're a year plus into this new
marriage with a kid and all of a sudden
you feel things starting to slip through
your fingers and you are a control
person
[Music]
she can't love your wives and
spreadsheets all the time sometimes yes
but most of the time it's best just to
sit and listen say tell me what we're
working through
[Music]
I'm grateful for you Lola thank you so
so much for the call
um holler back at me when you decide
what to do I'm gonna hear how this one
ends we'll be right back
all right we're back let's go to the bar
Buffalo New York Dr Jerry what's up
Jerry
hi Dr D how are you so much for taking
my call I'm I'm operating breathing so
it's a good day that's a good one
excellent what's happening what's up
oh I am having issues with my adult
daughter okay um
the last few years it's it's gotten way
worse we have you know constant blow-ups
and then well
we'll sit down and talk and things will
be better for a while
um I find myself walking on eggshells
around her but you know we kind of get
through it um is she is she an addict
that she used
no no not at all um she's very very
angry
um
um
my ex-husband when she was growing up
they had a chip where they were either
really getting along or they really
weren't
and he uh they were in an argument one
day and he pushed her
and she feels I didn't do anything about
it she's right I
I should have left right then and there
yeah
um
oh but well I the last time that we had
this
um a blow up the blow-ups are over other
things but it always goes back to you
know deep down she's angry with me and I
get it
and I've apologized and I've offered to
you know I've asked her to please go to
counseling because I you know I use your
analogy of you're drinking poison
waiting for him to die it's just it's
crazy
so
um it's gotten even worse in the last
year and a half
um she left her husband
um she was got really angry because we
were also friends with him
so our point was well he's the father of
our grandchild so
so we gave in and
none of us are friends with him anymore
you know we we keep our distance uh
um but every time we have these blow-ups
she won't let me see the grandchildren
why do you why do you keep having
blow-ups with her
um
we'll just set her off
I know but you know those things
why do you engage her yes why I I I I
don't think I do I like I told you I
tiptoe around her and I hate that
feeling but I I know what sets her off
the problem is
she has a very very good relationship
with my my husband
um
she you know doesn't have a good
relationship with her dad she confides
in my husband and I love seeing her have
somebody like that
um but I think he him and I have been
talking the last couple weeks because it
I'm really at a Crossroads I don't know
what to do
I think he fuels the fire like he
doesn't understand you know he says
little things to her that I would never
you know I can fight in him and then
he I don't think he means to
you know weak things to her
but there are things that I know are
gonna set her off
um an example is she asked me to go to
dinner with her a couple months ago
which we used to do everything together
when she was little I mean we baked we
exercised we shopped we did everything
together I was there for both of the
kids I was in the room when both of them
were born
um but like a couple months ago she had
asked me to go out to dinner and like I
said we've been strained the last you
know two or three years
so I said to my husband I'm like I'm
like that's kind of uh I'm like it's
nice yes I want to go to dinner I'm like
and uh you know I was hoping for good
things well he
said something to her that you know he's
like I don't know why you YouTube
questioning each other so then she got
mad at me because I questioned why she
wanted to go out to dinner
so
your husband is not at fault here okay
yeah
no he's very much a sticker yeah I know
I know but let me
just uh
I want you just to settle in for a
second okay
yep
whether she knows it or not there's
still a little girl in there wondering
what was it about that guy that was more
important than me when we when I was
little
right why did my mom pick him over me
and
the way even the way you said that that
when things were good they were so good
and they were bad they were really bad
when that happens with a kid there is no
real good
and that usually is somebody trying to
balance out their inaction
or excuse some of their inaction okay
you said it you're right you should have
left you should have left before he
pushed her but here we are I also know
um not purse not firsthand but I've sat
with enough people to know
the fear of being a single parent the
economic insecurity the the I understand
the plight women have to go through
to eat some I get it it's a mess and
it's easy to look back 25 or 30 years
later and go I should have I should have
I should have and then in the middle of
it you start to think well the next stop
is the back of our station wagon and I
don't have it right and so here we are
now
and the we used to do everything
together cool that is in the past and
the more you go back to there you are
choosing to drink poison
we got to be right here right now
you're walking on eggshells around her
is a anxiety response she cannot anchor
into you because you're not fully
present you keep secrets from her you
don't tell her the truth you don't tell
her everything
and when you don't she knows it she
knows she's being angry and unreasonable
and annoying and frustrated she knows
that
and she also knows Mom's not telling me
the truth
and mom's still trying to treat me like
I'm 10.
think about it she laughed
let me say it this way you might think
you're a safe place her behavior is
telling us all that you she does not see
that
right okay so the goal is less how do I
get her to do what I want
the goal is how do I become a safe place
for her not a doormat
how do I become a safe place
and and that's what I'm looking for I I
don't have the tools to you know our our
last blow up um I I told I
you know she's very much
a yeller and
I and I told her I you know I I
understand if you're upset with me but
please sit down and talk to me so we did
we sat and talked for three hours and I
and I thought we really got to a much
better place
um and I told her I can't I can't go
back and fix anything I've done I was a
young mother I had no idea what I was
doing that's right um I said I can't fix
any of that but what I can do is do
better going forward and here's the hard
part here's the hard part
yeah what you just said is
is gold
it's such a gift
and that's the extent of what you can do
and if she chooses to not plug back in
that's a choice she's making
right and it hurts like bloody hell
it does
I made a million mistakes when my kids
are growing up
um I have a very good relationship with
my son
um don't don't compare them
no no I I don't I don't want to do that
I I want to fix for
for her and I I want to be there for
there for her I
I to see her hurting like this that's
right I mean she's definitely hurting
and I I don't I hate seeing that and the
other thing is is every time she you
know she knows the one thing that she
can get to me with is these
grandchildren and they're seeing this
and and I they're looking I can't get
through to her that they're seeing how
to treat a mother you know when they get
older
I I don't want to see them doing this to
you and you're trade showing them how to
be you know what to be to women and and
their future why that's true but flip
around the other side
I've been really frustrated with my
parents before real frustrated actually
I've never once a thought I need to keep
my kids from them
exactly and I said hold on hold on hold
on
it could be that she's evil she's just
evil and she's weaponizing her children
to get back at her mother for something
her mother did 25 years ago I don't
think that's the case I think that she
doesn't think you're safe
okay
I can agree with that and so
let's don't demonize her even if she's
doing stupid things
okay let's go back to the basics the OG
Basics what can you control your
thoughts and your actions that's it
that's it okay you cannot control this
young girl you've been trying her whole
life and you can't and you also can't go
back and undo what happened it happened
you got to own it and you have which is
impressive but what you haven't done is
started trying to write something new
you keep going trying to go back and
edit it I know right you got it happened
it is and these grandkids are not your
Redemption story they're not your
do-over
they're new people they're new people
and so
I would sit down and really map out what
are my boundaries
and a gift for her that's not going to
feel like a gift at first
is saying hey I'm not gonna I'm I'm not
gonna do blow-ups with you anymore I
love you too much and I'm not interested
in going to war with you I'm interested
in loving you and being a safe place
you've never been a safe place I I know
I know
um but I'm working on it now and so when
you raise your voice that's you choosing
to end a conversation with me
okay in these three hour marathons feel
so cathartic
but they're not accomplishing anything
okay are they
I I thought you feel better you feel
better yeah but when you're talking to
somebody in fight or flight you're not
they're calming down but there's no
resolution
okay and a lot of times the resolution
after one of those three hour marathon
talks is people are exhausted they're
tired they're dropping their shoulders
for the first time in a long time
because their bodies aren't at War
and then the neck you got to do those
things you you got to teach your body
over time there's not this one big
conversation that's going to accomplish
everything
but again you're trying to find the
right thing to say trying to find the
right thing to do trying to find
laugh
your daughter feels that you're trying
to Puppet Master still after all these
years
and it's going to be you saying I'm just
not going to do that anymore I love you
too much I love those kids too much I
love you
I'm not gonna fight you
yeah I I can feel the anxiety when when
we're together and it never used to be
like that but but you I want you to take
full ownership I have found myself
getting anxious around my own daughter
and yes you should be the one safe place
for me besides my husband
and that's on me I'm gonna stop being
anxious around you but that also means
you're going to stop you I I'm not I'm
just going to choose to opt out when you
yell
because I'm worth more than that and I'm
going to choose to opt out when you
swear at me and if you choose to take
the Korean kids away I'm I'm gonna
choose to have my heart broken but I'm
not gonna fight you
I'm just not gonna fight you anymore
well and that's where I'm at like I'm
I'm not okay not seeing these these
grandkids for but you don't get a vote
Jerry
you know you know what I mean
yeah you don't get a vote
and my husband you know
you know before I reached back out to
her I feel like I need to work on me a
little bit like there's this is just a
cycle that I just I want to get out of
so maybe you you can do both it's not
either or
okay maybe you reach out and say
um even take a disproportionate amount
of the blame
okay but
I would have a conversation with her
that's really somewhat jerry-centric
very you centered
okay
I'm sorry how I've acted
and I'm your mom and I feel anxious
around you and I'm not doing that
anymore because I love you too much
this isn't War this is you're my
daughter
and I'm committed to my own growth I
can't change you I can't change your
decisions to take the kids away but I
can become a safer place
and okay by becoming a safer place I'm
going to have boundaries and if you
don't like the boundaries that's fine
I'm just not gonna fight you anymore and
I'm going to see my own counselor I'm
going to go work on me and I'd love for
you to come with me
and if you don't want to great yeah cool
but here's the thing she will naturally
be drawn to you like a tractor beam
the more stable and safe and firm you
feel
okay okay the more you're trying to have
a new plan and you read a new book and
watched and read a new Instagram post
and you're gonna fix her on that dude
she can feel it a hundred miles away
okay
and think about how much more peaceful
of a life you're gonna have
yeah yeah and that's the thing I'm at a
Crossroads like I can't I can't feel
like this anymore set the swords down
set them just set them down
yeah no more fighting
I'm not gonna do blow-ups I'm not gonna
do War I'm not gonna do any of it I will
be gut-wrenched if you take those if you
don't let me see the kids
but I also know they're your kids and I
can't fight you over them
if they're ever being abused or unsafe
I'm gonna call every Authority I have
but you don't have to bring that up in
this conversation
right right and and no I mean it's it's
you know not a situation like that I
just
it's exhausting and I know it's
exhausting for her too and I want to be
able to help her like she you know she
works full-time and she does very well
she's you know but I want to be able to
help her you know if she needs I know
but she's not asking for your help I
know you have to reconcile that
the more you try to insert yourself into
her life
the more it's just going to be an
electrified situation
the more you become a safe place
the more you're going to end up seeing
those grandkids the more you're going to
end up seeing her and the more you're
all gonna be able to heal your
relationship
okay
does that make sense
it does I heard over the weekend I don't
know how much truth this is
um I was at an event in Phoenix and
somebody was telling me that
um
I think it was I think it's where I
think anyway it doesn't matter where I
heard it
um that memorable Gorbachev and uh
Ronald Reagan
when they were figuring out communism
and capitalism and and they had they
were meeting and they were in a heated
heated argument
about how stupid your capitalism is and
how damaging your your
um communism is a back and forth back
and forth in the room they said it was
getting hotter and hotter and hotter
like two egotistical world leaders
getting ready to get pushed over the
edge right
and out of nowhere they said Reagan
disengages and walks away which is a
very strange move
okay and he said he walked away and was
gone for a minute and then Circle back
and walked back in with his with a huge
smile on his face
in an outstretched hand like to shake
his hand
and he said something like hey Mikey my
name's Ronnie how are you doing
and they both it was so the tint they
both started laughing and he reset it
I'm not fighting you we got to be
friends yeah
that's the only way this thing works
moving forward right or everybody ends
up in Ash and again I don't know how
much of that story is folklore I know
how much that story is real but the
sentiment behind it is true there comes
a moment when we get so angry and so
frustrated we fall over the edge and
before you fall over the edge you're the
adult you're the mom you're the parent
she's an adult too but you're the parent
um I'm stepping away I'm gonna Circle
back I'm gonna take my time I'm gonna
take a breath I'm gonna come back in
with a smile and say
yeah this is different from this point
forward and you are going to sleep
better
yeah because you're tired of War too
right yeah yeah and that's what I meant
by I I need to work on me I I mean
obviously I'm you know pushing buttons
and I'm you're right I try to edit the
past and I I'm the one that told her I
can't do that I can't fix any of it but
I can do better going forward and I
still go to the past but and you're
going forward is a trying to erase the
past and rewrite it can't do that you're
going forward is you trying to acutely
insert yourself into her life which she
has not asked for you trying to give her
parenting advice and mothering advice
and help I'll help you I'll help you I'm
not asking for your help I just want my
mom
yeah
and you have a picture in your head of
what Grandma's supposed to be doing with
their kids and that's not the picture
that your daughter has and if you want
to be in a relationship with her and
your grandkids her picture is the one
that's going to matter
it's like when somebody says hey my kids
decided they're not coming up for
Christmas I'm so ticked off I'm pissed
I'm gonna call them why
because they're not gonna come for
Christmas either
yeah and that's it all of that is an
antidote to sitting down to not wanting
to sit down and go I'm really sad that
my kids aren't going to be here for
Thanksgiving my Thanksgiving is going to
look different now I'm going to have to
invite people over and it's going to be
kind of boring or weird right I've got
to deal with the Reality Part
and so I'd love to see you create an
anti-war document
this is full of your boundaries
here's what I'm not going to tolerate
you can't cuss at me you can't just show
up here in the middle of the night if I
find out you're using or the kids aren't
safe I'm gonna call you on it here's my
boundaries
and then I think your husband's right
reach out and but the reaching out is a
declaration of peace and it's a
declaration of I'm changing and I love
you and I
here's the deal that's all you got left
and everybody listening to this if you
find yourself
like like Jerry you're what you're
talking about is so common it's common
in marriages it's common between parents
and young kids it just turns into the
cycle of I will defeat you I will solve
you I will I've got bigger muscles than
you I I've got more power than you
and it just ends in ashes
and at some point someone's got to back
out and just say hey control alt delete
reset I'm not going to war with you
anymore I'm choosing a path of peace and
here's what this is going to look like
and you'll sleep and they'll sleep and
that is the soil of new trees
I'm proud of you Jerry it's gonna be
tough because you're gonna have to
unlearn a whole bunch of actions you're
gonna have to learn how to breathe
you're gonna have to learn how to get up
and walk away you're gonna have to learn
how to get in the car and not have had
the last word
and you're also gonna have to learn how
to be a grandma because you're going to
start seeing those kids more and more
the safer your daughter feels around you
you can do this you can do this we'll be
right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships I'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up where you can
share hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to John deloney.com to
take the next step towards Wellness
that's own your past change your future
at John deloney.com
all right we are back and we're wrapping
it up today the song of the day is by
the great coin
yep the band's called coin not coins
just one one coin and the song is talk
too much and it goes like this
caffeine Small Talk weight out the
plastic weather uh discussing current
events I'll take my time I'm not the
forward thinker you read my mind better
to leave it unsaid why can't I leave it
unsaid you know I talk too much honey
come put your lips on mine and shut me
up we could blame it all on human nature
stay cool it's just a kiss why gotta be
so talkative I talk too much we talk too
much
lucky for you America I don't talk too I
talk so way too much for more of me
talking too much we'll see you next time